Hey, what's going on? It's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast at all.
Ah,
just check it it on you.
I'm just checking in to see how
your week's going. You know,
you know who I'm talking
about. Oh, you brave warriors,
you social justice people you know,
misunderstood,
uh, you suffering white women
and you're fucking SUV. I just,
you know what you do day in and day out
is so difficult and I'm just checking in
to make sure that you're living your
truth and whatever else is written on your
fucking yoga pants.
How are you everybody?
I'm in New York City,
New York City,
skyscrapers and everything. Um, yeah.
Been here for a couple days and a,
I'm having a good time doing stand up.
You know,
even though it's like doing fucking
standup at a woman's college now I can,
I have never
this trip,
I swear to fucking Christ.
I've gotten more grown standing
on stage doing my bullshit act.
Then I got my entire time when I lived
here for New York for like 10 years.
Like it's,
it's fucking crazy.
What has happened to this comedy?
This was one.
This used to be one of the
great comedy cities. Oh my God.
Okay.
Each stand on stage,
you feel like somebody is like fucking
stepping on a puppy behind you.
You're like, what did I say?
What? What happened? Ah,
the old time.
I am really holding on to this,
this hope that this is just a ridiculous
phase that this country is going
through this ridiculous phase where we
have allowed like 8% of the population
and they're unbelievably extreme lunatic
ideas to push us so far to the fucking
left that me as a lefty,
like now I feel like,
do I need to start watching
fucking Fox News is this way?
The middle is now watching those cons
on that fucking channel. I mean, I,
I don't know what to do here.
Yeah,
I dunno. All I can tell you is when I
did stand up over in Europe, like the,
the level that they
were laughing at us for,
what the fuck we're doing because
we're all in a bubble over here.
I don't know what the deal is,
but I think it's a sad state that I
went to formerly communist Europe.
Um, and I felt freer to speak
over there then I fucking do here.
It's unbelievable. Oh. Um,
but actually not in
defense of New York City.
I think I've been going
further in the grown direction.
Okay.
Just as a reaction to it.
Like,
okay.
So I,
I could give myself some space.
Yeah.
You know, it's, it's
fucking claustrophobic.
I don't,
I really don't understand.
I just don't understand that adults
going to comedy shows and um,
I don't know. You know what?
But you know, it was great.
Was the Patrice O'Neal comedy
benefit that was fucking phenomenal.
And um,
actually one of the comics,
Mark Norman had a fucking
great joke on shit like that,
about people getting offended,
which I won't tell cause it's his joke.
So go out and go see him live.
Um,
thank you to everybody on
that came out this year.
I don't have the names in front of me,
so I know I'm going to forget somebody.
Michelle Wolf, Jay Oakerson, rich vos
hosting it for the seventh year in a row.
Mark Norman Joe Lists, uh, Gary Gulman,
Chris read a Mama, Mama, Mama. I know.
I'm forgetting like two or three people.
I don't,
everybody went out and
fucking killed. It was, uh,
you know, we got great feedback
about it. It was just, it's just,
it's one of my favorite things in
the world to do. And like I said,
all the money goes to,
uh, his mom and, um,
his wife and, uh, you know,
and people have asked, well,
why do you do it every single
year? You know, it's like, well,
we just one theater gig and Patrice
was supporting those people.
And I always hated when somebody dies.
You do like one fucking, you do it once.
He like up gay.
There's a sack of money trying to stretch
that out for the next fucking 20, 30,
50, 60 years that you'll live in. You
know, um, he was taking care of him.
So, uh, he unfortunately passed away.
So all the comics make sure that we were
taking care of who Patrice was taken
care of. So, um, like I said,
all they should have to deal with
is the grief of him not being here.
Other than that, you know, we should all
be helping them out, which we're doing.
So thank you from the bottom of my heart
to everybody who shows up to the thing
and everybody comes out and donates
their free time. Oh, Maureen Taren,
who puts the whole thing
together. Um, it's, it's, uh,
it's just awesome. So, uh, we're already
thinking about the lineup for next year,
going to see if I can get Paul Versey,
you know,
got to get versus you to come
down. Uh, for some dumb reason,
I haven't asked him to do it yet. There's
always somebody every year. I'm like,
why the fuck haven't I asked that person
yet? So, uh, that is the deal. Um,
anyways, let's talk in
the news. Oh my God.
You know, everybody is
talking about this, uh,
this Jessie Smith and Lewinsky,
whatever his fucking name is. Juicy,
juicy, small. Let
Jesse Smollett.
Everybody's talking about that.
But I don't think that's
the biggest news. And, uh,
the biggest story in the news right now,
I think it's Zion Williamson's Nike.
Okay.
The brand that Paul Versey love,
like it literally exploded on his
foot and caused him to have injury.
No,
I can't imagine how many older white guys
like me with the dad bod that are now
going to reconsider buying Nikes because
if it can't withstand the power of Zion
Williamson, how is it with Stan? Me,
I'm trying to think of some dad shit.
I'm unfolding a stroller.
Oh God. Can you imagine what those
evil constant run Nike. Can you Matt?
I bet there.
I bet they have this serial number on
that sneaker and they are tracking down
that fucking four year old
that glued that thing together.
Oh my God. What are they
going to, Oh, Jesus Christ.
The probably going to hang them upside
down for the next month by his fucking
toes.
Okay.
Would make him wear Adidas or some shit.
I don't know what,
but I can tell you something right now.
They are rejoicing at Adidas, Reebok,
uh, pro keds. Whoever else makes fucking
sneakers. I gotta be honest with you, man.
I that is like, I have not seen a
guy this sound Williamson, this,
if you miss Bo Jackson,
like this is what you're watching.
Like somebody who just comes along,
I mean he's literally what
the fuck this guy did.
Like I could not do that to a
sneaker if I got hit by a car,
I'd have to get hit by some farm equipment
and lose my leg for my sneaker to
look like that. That was just
the sheer strength of this man.
Okay.
Making a cut or whatever. I
have no idea. But that reminded,
the only thing I'd ever seen like that
is you ever watched that shit on Bo
Jackson?
Uh,
how he ended up having that career
ending injury is he was running with such
speed and had like a 250 lineback pound
linebacker hanging on his leg as he
continued to drag the guy
down the field and just,
yeah,
it was weird.
It was like his own strength
worked against him because
anybody else would have
just fell down like a fucking sack of
potatoes and he continued to run with 250
fucking pounds hanging on
them. Um, unbelievable.
So I help that kids. All right.
I heard he is all right. Um,
I'm sure nobody on the tar heels side of
the fucking court was upset that he was
out for most of the game. I think he came
back. I don't even know what happened.
I'm missing everything. Like my
Boston Bruins. Hey, we go bro.
Weds here we go.
Um,
have one seven in a row and I've missed
every game. I've been following it. Um,
I heard there was a high stick goal that
we got away with against the La Kings
or whatever and uh,
so we ended up winning in overtime.
We just one in a shootout
against Vancouver. Um, you know,
big, big, big points,
getting 14 points out of 14 points
this time a year going into March,
moving up the playoff thing. I think
we said they move it up to, uh,
the sixth seat or something like that.
Sweet 16.
I don't know what the fuck they said,
but all I know is what playing well.
So that makes me happy. And when I get
on the other side of my special here, uh,
I will be looking forward to maybe
take it in a game two. Um, all right,
so let's talk about Joe.
Just smaller.
Yeah.
Jesus fucking cry. Like I had been
watching this story just cringing,
you know, in the beginning it was
depressing. Like Jesus Christ.
Like why would somebody do
that to somebody? But then
when it started to unravel,
yeah,
yeah. Just like, oh no, please no.
Okay,
please tell me you didn't do this to your
first fucking guys on like one of the
biggest shows on fucking TV.
If this is true.
Okay.
That's why I don't like talking
about it like until it's like proven,
but it's looking fucking bed.
Okay.
What, you know, you know what I mean?
You know what's fucked up is everybody,
doesn't everybody have like
a hero fantasy? You know,
we stop a bank robbery
of stops of terrorists.
He ended up landing the plane or some
shit and next thing you know you're,
you're on Oprah and she's
talking to you just go and like,
how are you so amazing?
And you're like, ah,
you know, shucks, I was just
doing my job as a passenger.
I did what anybody else you say of all
your raw shucks slides and then all of a
sudden you're like,
you wake up from the interview when
you realize you just drive it down the
street and you'll,
or you were talking to yourself
and somebody saw you w you know,
at least performers.
We're all a little bit nuts like that,
but to fucking follow through with it.
Okay.
Then this guy,
you ever watched the first 48
some of the ways they catch people now I,
it's weird because I should be rooting
for them, but it's just, you just,
I watched some of these forensic
shows. It's like, oh, what the fuck?
You can figure it out from that.
Okay.
I remember one time this guy suffocated
this woman using a fucking garbage bag
and they somehow found her,
her fucking face in the bag.
You know,
I gotta hand it to murderous though.
I don't know if that just
caught up in the emotion of it,
but like they're fucking belief in
themselves that they're going to get away
with this shit. They should really just
watch a couple episodes. I like that.
The first 48 or,
or one of these forensics fucking chills.
I don't know how anybody gets
away with anything, but um,
I got us, be honest with you
now that it's unraveling.
Okay.
The bleach, the maggot hat magnet.
What does it make? America great again.
Mag a mag. I had the fucking,
uh, the noose around his neck.
It all kind of reads like, you know, when
you do a first table, read up a script,
you know, you're like, all right,
it's getting there to get he,
he should have workshop that a
little more. I would have gone,
would not have had the hat, wouldn't have
had the new [inaudible]. Oh, the news.
So whatever. You know what
it's like. It's like, you know,
when one of the starlight
goes out and they,
they accessorize too much and
then they go, you know what,
when it right before you go out,
take two things off.
Like that's what he should've done.
Should've got rid of the
news and the fucking hat.
Uh,
I don't get it.
The only thing that doesn't
make sense if this was fake,
like what kind of a fucking asshole
for 3,500 bucks is going to go to jail
and then have a hate crime on your
fucking record for the rest of your life?
I guess they were assuming that they
were going to get away with it. Um,
I dunno man. It's just the, I is
it weird? I feel bad for the guy.
It just reminds me when I was a kid and
I started lying to my parents and it
just fucking got out of
control and then it's so all,
you know what it reminds me
of. Okay. This is a true story.
I'm going to show you my,
my Jesse.
So we all got a little Jesse
similar smell let in us. Right.
Okay. So one time when I was in my
first year of first grade, right.
I loved it so much. I did it twice. Um,
when it came to school I was like,
that fucking hurdler who just hit the
first fucking hurdle and fell on his
goddamn face in the fucking race
was just over, you know, that was,
that was my school career. So anyways, um,
that was one of the
first jokes I ever wrote.
Talking about the second year of first
grade, how fucking boring it was.
Cause you learn how to read. You literally
learn how to read the first grade.
At least you did back then.
So I remember like the first three months
being bored out of my mind is these
kids with sounding out the words
they was sitting next to me,
go and look to Duh in my
joke am my hack was duck.
The word is duck to matter.
The picture didn't give it away.
That was my first really decent laugh.
I got my left and am I act it was,
it was clean.
People thought I was on my way to doing
the tonight show with Johnny Carson.
That's how long ago this
was. Um, so anyways,
I was in my first year of first
grade and there was these two twins.
All right. And I had a crush on
one of them. Her name was Gwen
and I can't remember the other
one's name. Right. And, uh,
so anyway, I think I might have told this
story before on the podcast. Right. But,
so we're fucking, um, Aman,
she's not in my class.
I'm in the other class with their sister
and her sister had this giant pink pen.
Like, I dunno why it was like, like if
it would be like the size of a number
two pencil for like fucking Andre the
giant. I don't know why she had the giant
thing and for whatever reason, you know,
I just looked at, I thought, I
dunno, I just looked different.
I thought it was cool.
So she dropped it on the floor and we
had like all four of our desks where were
like made into a circle.
She had like groups of four going around
the teacher and it fell on the fucking
floor.
And um,
I fucking picked it up. And like an idiot.
This is how dumb I was. I pick it up.
And rather than,
than just stealing it,
I just take it and I
start writing with it.
Like in the same fucking circle is her.
So she looks over at me and she goes, hey,
that's my pen. And I go,
no, it isn't a, it's mine.
So this is where my Jessie story
starts. If this guy's guilty, right.
And I stick with this fucking story. She
goes up to the teacher and she goes, hey,
you took my pen and I'm going,
no, it's not her pen. It's my pen.
It's a giant pink fucking pen.
And the teacher just looks at me and
she goes, you know, I think it's so,
it's so spent. I go,
no it isn't. It's mine.
And then she described this crack that
was in it, like to a t or whatever.
And of course I got busted
and the teacher's just
looking at me like, you know,
look at this little fucking Klepto Ron
Howard looking motherfucker. Right?
So what have, you know, you're a little
kid, you blow it off 10 minutes late,
you're probably talking to the person.
You just did that too. But anyways,
so the next day I go to school and
in between, like during the class,
I went to go to the bathroom.
It just so happened that go Gwyn that I
had the crush on. She just looks at me,
she goes,
I heard what you did to my sister.
She had his fucking look at her
face and she fucking hated me.
And I just turned around and walked away.
Heartbroken to the, uh, to the bathroom,
knowing that the first girl
I had a crush on now, no.
Said I'm a complete piece of shit.
Um,
and that was probably the first stepping
stone onto me becoming a fucking lonely
comedian.
I Dunno how that ties into this just
sees small lip at this. Oh my God.
He imagined it and that's a
fucking felony. I didn't know that.
Faking a police report.
The AG Ed. Yeah. He almost,
I'm satisfactory. They don't do that. Um,
I guess it makes sense to,
the cops will be pissed if
you fake something like all
the fucking work they got
to do.
You know what I mean?
Putting this whole God damn file together
and like this shit doesn't make sense.
It's like having write somebody
a term paper for you and
it's like, oh yeah, yeah,
yeah. Just fucking with you. I'm
not going to pay for that. And uh,
I'd never really had to do a term paper.
And what the fuck was I doing over here
for the last guy? Damn. Three weeks.
Okay.
Um, anyways, I got nothing to talk
about. I am so fucking lonely right now.
It's fucking ridiculous. Um,
but my, my, my wife and kid
are going to be flying out,
meet me soon. I can't wait.
Thank God for facetime.
All I do is sing baby shark.
Get my kid going. You know.
And then it's funny too is
I say this thing like she
always goes push the button,
push the button cause she wants to
hang up. So I just go, don't do it.
Don't push that button.
Don't push that.
But as she gets this big grin on her face,
she loves nothing more.
And right as I see her about radio laugh,
her face just disappears
and then I become sad.
Anyways,
Karl Lagerfeld died according
to the New York Post.
Jesus Christ.
I know that.
How sad and pathetic as this podcasts
right now is saying it's his cat might get
millions. I gotta be honest with
you. Think I trashed fat people.
You should see fucking Karl Lagerfeld,
Lara field, whatever his fucking name is.
Um,
he's just what he was,
I guess he was at a fashion giant and
he was very impressed with himself. Um,
all right.
Somebody is about to get a golden litter
box among those who could inherit a big
hunk of the designer.
Karl Lagerfeld's,
$125 million fortune is
the love of his law life.
His celebrity cat
is it shall pay.
Is that how you say show pet? Is that
an American would say chill pet show,
pay all,
um,
Lagerfeld 85 who die Tuesday in Paris
made it clear in the past that his Blue
Wide Berman Kitty meant so much to him.
Yeah.
Uh, that she would find a
place in his will. Yeah.
We probably knew like this
dude cats live like 18 years.
You get one when you're 71 or whatever.
No wait,
he was 85 probably got this
thing when he was like 80.
He's probably be like, well this thing
just going to get fucking put down.
That's not going to happen.
It's guys a good shit. You know?
I know he trashed fat people in short
men and all of that type of stuff.
I thought he was fucking hilarious.
You know,
there's a few people out there that I
think should have been stand up comedians
instead of what they did,
even though they were wildly successful.
Like both those brothers
that are in oasis,
I half the shit I read that they say I
like this shit's funnier than anything
I've ever fucking said.
These guys really should put down
their fucking Ukuleles and shit.
They should go on a fucking standup tour.
I'm not saying I don't love their music,
I'm just saying,
and this Karl Lagerfeld, some of the
shit that this guy said, it's like,
just look up at this guy's quotes.
Okay.
He was, he, he was like so
fucking mean. It's funny,
you know,
unless you live here and then you're
triggered and then everything needs to
stop.
And we up the fucking
okay.
Do you know I have a friend of mine,
somebody said to words said, uh,
okay.
You know, hey, you know,
I'm really hungry. I'm going
to go get something to eat.
And she wrote back, she goes,
me too. And then she wrote,
not me too with like the Hashtag. Hahaha.
And then the friend got all offended.
Like, that isn't funny. You
shouldn't joke about that if we joke,
but it's like we're doing in between
each other. You're a fucking idiot.
Nothing's happening here.
And she literally had to talk this
person off of a fucking emotional ad,
like ledge. That's where we're at. Okay.
That's where we're at in
this country right now.
And maybe that's why in
this current comedy climate,
somebody like this fucking poor bastard
decided to fucking fake this goddamn
thing. I guess. You know what?
They give you a shit cause they could
actually be out there solving real crimes.
They you go build that only took your
fucking 20 minutes to figure out,
okay,
oh I could have been working
on this domestic violence case,
but I was this and there are also
probably had like this high level of like
priority
Jesus Christ.
Is this going to make a
great made for TV movie?
You know what?
I think considering magnum Pi
is not a white guy anymore.
I'm throwing my hat in the ring to play
Jessie Smollett in this, uh, you know,
just a ballad shit out.
All right.
If a, why didn't they give, why didn't
they give magnum a new fucking Ferrari?
Why is he still driving around in that
fucking thing? You know, that's one of,
there was one of the worst
Ferrari's ever made. Why can,
why can't she give the guy a
nice ride? You know? Does that,
does that make sense to anybody? I was
so far. I mean I liked it. It was a nice,
cool, that should be like his fucking
weekend driver. You know what I mean?
Like that was his high school car.
So he kept it or maybe like, I dunno,
maybe Tom Selleck fucking saved him
from drowning when he was a kid.
Right after he banged that
chicken, the bikini, you know,
from the opening credits.
Then he's like, oh look at this. I was
bagging you hear in the sand and there's,
there's a little fucking kid out. They're
drowning. When are you saved them?
He takes them in now they'll world
don't move to the beat of just one drum.
We're stuck here on this island,
but we're having fun. Right.
Right in the friary you can
sit on the fucking console.
Cause I got some hot ass sitting
in the passengers to see, um,
then he could have taken
over the business. Right.
You just have Tom sell x, uh,
you know, his character dies. How I
would've done it. His character is dying.
You know, you make it like
somehow like a hot button issue.
Like he dies of like a, I don't,
I don't know what prostate can't,
nobody gives a shit about prostate cancer.
He dies of male breast cancer. Okay.
In October.
And the NFL recognizes it by having pink
mustaches put on top of that helmets,
like looking like Lyft drivers.
Okay.
In his dying words are tells this kid
to take over the business and he's like,
and I want you to take care of my
car. Made sure she's okay. Right.
So on very special assignments.
No,
whenever he takes a woman out on the
show, you know, I'm sorry, a warrior,
a brave, courageous, so brave
to get in those tee tops.
Uh, that t top car and then he just takes
them up on it. But the rest of the show,
he has a brand new fucking Ferrari,
you know,
they chases people down in the street.
And that's how I would
have done it personally.
Okay.
I don't want, I don't want to, you
know, I'm not trashing the show,
I'm just saying, you know, it's a
network show. I know you got the budget.
You could have hooked the
guy up with a new Ferrari.
Okay.
Right. I Dunno. I'd probably taken all
this shit to fucking seriously. Yeah,
I watched that show. I didn't know. I
didn't know what was up. What was down.
Higgins is a woman now. I, I don't
get it. That's like the new thing.
You just do something that's already done,
but then you just switch everything
up. Yeah. This used to be a black guy.
Now it's a parrot. This was a white guy.
Now he's Puerto Rican. This was a guy,
now it's a woman and a,
it's the same fucking shell.
You know what they're doing right now.
They're doing what Hanna Barbera did
with all of their fucking cartoons with
Hanna Barbera. God bless them
because they did Johnny quest,
my favorite fucking cartoon of all time.
But those motherfuckers plagiarize
themselves like 58 fucking times.
They had the Scooby Doo than
they are the Scooby Doo rip off.
They had the Flintstones,
which was a rip off of the honeymooners,
and it was just placed in the stone age.
And then they did the sort of did
the same fucking show and the future.
What the Jetsons,
I forgot I had this all mapped out
how they fucking rip themselves off.
And then in the end they combined all of
their characters and had these cartoon
Olympics called the laugh Olympics,
but somewhere. But it was all worth it.
It was all worth it because at jinx
the cat and uh, and Johnny quest.
All right. And with that, let me
read a, let me read this here.
A quip,
one of the most important things we do
for our health every day is brushing our
teeth.
Yet most of us don't do it properly.
How do you not do it properly? I
mean, it's fucking, it's right there.
Slide your tongue across your teeth. Does
it feel gross? Which one feels gross?
Brush that one extra quip is a better
electric toothbrush created by dentists
and designers. Finally, they consulted
the dentist. They got the pros in there.
Quip was designed to make brushing
your teeth more simple, affordable,
and even enjoyable.
I love this sensitive sonic vibrations.
Sorry, I have to do the sound effects
here. This is a very low budget.
Read gentle enough on your sensitive gums.
Why people brush too hard and some
electric toothbrushes are too abrasive.
They could explain that better.
If you brushed too hard,
you're actually going to
slowly wear away your gumline,
which is going to lead to way a,
a periodontal issue because what happens
is is that a namel is on the party,
a tooth that that lives above the gum.
All right below your gum,
it doesn't have any enamel because
it's supposed to be covered by the gum.
It's protected there, so then when
you start brushing too hard, um,
you wear that away and eventually that
part gets exposed and it's way more
susceptible to tooth decay.
Then what happens is eventually you're,
you're looking at a crown or a root
canal or God forbid you lose a tooth.
Now when you lose a tooth,
okay,
you have to go to the fucking dentist and
you have to get something put in there
because what happens is,
is the teeth next to it move to the side
to try to close up the space and the
tooth directly below it will erupt upwards
to fill in that fucking space to help
fill it in.
And then when it erupts upwards,
you got that party a tooth that doesn't
an AML on it and that's exposed and then
you lose that fucking tooth and then
everybody starts fucking moving around.
Yeah,
it's a fucking shit show.
You know what it's like.
You ever seen those special forces?
When they did,
they got a hold the fucking log up to
become like an army ranger and if one guy
fucking quits,
then they all the other fucking guys,
then they have to hold his weight
up. They don't get to quit. Right?
It's kind of the same thing.
But anyways,
it's a builtin two minute timer that
pulses every 30 seconds to remind you when
to switch sides,
helping guide of full and even clean so
you can be an absolute fucking moron and
do it properly. Uh, up to 90% of us
don't brush for a full two minutes.
I guess I don't,
I guess I'm a moron or don't clean evenly.
A multiuse cover mounts to your mirror
and announced to slide over your bristle
a four on the go. Brushing.
Say why you love quip.
I love quip cause they're paying me
to say it. That's why I love quip. No,
I love anything.
Anybody to be honest with you.
Anybody that's helping you
take care of your teeth.
It's a number one fucking thing.
So number one, God damn thing,
you take care of your teeth.
Like I like what you're going to
do for yourself in life. All right?
You chew your food properly.
You don't have your fucking teeth,
you're not going to do that.
It leads to stomach problems,
leaves the gun problems,
then he got problems in your ass.
And next thing you know, people are
coming by on your deathbed. All right.
Or he could just buy this toothbrush.
That's why I love quip and why
they're backed by over 20,000 dental
professionals. Quip starts at just
$25. If you get up, if you get,
if you go to get quip.com burner
right now slash bar right now,
I could read that better.
Get Quip Q u I p.com/burr.
Right now you get your first refill pack
for free with quip with a quip electric
toothbrush.
That's your first refill pack for free
and get quip.com/bird g e t Q u I p.
Dot com slash all capitals, B u r. R. Um,
but you are our, sorry,
hiccup there anyways,
um,
is that it?
Is that all that I had to talk
about tonight? I will be a,
I'll be at the west side comedy club
doing a little bit of time. Nothing crazy,
but I'm just going to be doing my set
until I fly over to jolly old England.
Make sure it's ready to go. And, uh,
I'm starting to get butterflies, man.
I'm like go almost a week out.
Monday will be a week out and I'm
getting ready to take this thing and I am
very, uh, anxious to do it
in a good way. I'm nervous,
but in a good way. And um, I dunno.
I can't, I can't fucking wait.
I cannot fucking wait and I'm
gonna run the set tonight.
What else did I want to talk
about? Ah, fuck. I just had it.
Yeah.
See that you haven't, and it
just goes away. You know why?
Cause I don't brush properly.
If I did two total when I brushed
my brain wouldn't be fucking Mush,
I guess. I have no fucking idea. Um,
anyways, and it was fucking hilarious.
It's not really hilarious.
I was walking up the street and I was in
a good mood and shit and there was this
homeless person and she goes,
can you spare some change or whatever?
And I was like, yeah, I can. So I
still say I might give a chance.
I don't have any change. I'll give a
dollar. So as I was reaching in to, uh,
give our dollar, I would, I, you know,
I felt weird because I was just standing
there. So I was just like, hey, you know,
how's it going?
I said,
how's it go into a fucking homeless
person? And she just answered me honestly.
She's like, well, I'm living in a shelter.
My Dad died. And I was like, all right.
All right. Dumb question. Kind of a
fucking idiot in my, you know, so I,
I enjoy and living on the street that
everything you thought it was going to be,
you know, I don't really think, when I
say before he speak a lot of the times,
and then I say it, and as it's coming up,
I'm like, why did I say that? You know?
But the good thing that I
have is I know I'm a moron.
I like to think this is one of my
better qualities is I know I'm a moron.
So as the person is fucking saying,
why did you say that?
I'm already agreeing with them. Like
I know, you're right. You're right.
I was stupid. So anyways, um,
I hoped as Jesse Smollett guy
somehow makes it come back.
If this is all true, IOB makes it come
back from this fucking shit. Jesus Christ.
You hate to see. Hate to see
it. Yeah. Hate to see it.
I've seen other people do shit like
this. It's just, I just, he fucking knew.
It's so fucking embarrassing.
It's fucking crazy to take
it to that lack of CIF.
He just did this amongst your
friends, you know, just tired.
One of your friends to punch you in the
lip and then you walk into a party got
jumped, but it fought him off. Oh my God.
He's so heroic. And next thing you know,
you're getting blown.
You know,
I can see the method to that madness,
but to take it to this fucking level,
you get to these fucking eight Gig,
come over the little fucking little
brush and they start Dustin Shit.
It's all going gonna fall apart.
There's security cameras.
You can't get away with shit.
And now all these fucking people,
they're sending their DNA into these
God damn things. It's, it's, it's,
it's a fucking rap.
It's a fucking rap.
Put my man, man voice back
on here. It is a fucking rap.
You're not going to be able to do shit.
And I'm at,
I'm not defended people doing
really crazy shit, but I mean,
you're not gonna be able to do shit.
You know what I mean?
Steal a Christmas tree sophomore at shit.
Right.
Go around knocking people's fucking
mailboxes off with a baseball bat.
Stupid Shit. Yeah. None of
that. It's all going to be,
there'll be a fucking drone following you
around suddenly had some in the future.
I swear to God,
these robots are going to show up at this
little dusty fucking things no matter
what. No matter what you do. Hmm.
You are at that parking meter
for all for 30 seconds more.
Here is your ticket. But I got out
of there before a cop came. Shut up.
We will eliminate you. Speaking of
eliminates from the first mammal.
I don't even know what it was.
This little field mouse became
extinct because of global warming.
Human caused global fucking warming.
Ah.
Was the news going to talk about that?
Going to talk about that?
That I talk about it. Nah, talk
you about it in the end. I Dunno.
I Dunno what the fucking solution is,
but I do know this.
When the water rises
up your flat screen TV,
you better get some flotation
devices for it. You know,
you know it going to survive all
the people that live in the middle,
middle of the country, as the water rises
up, they're going to fucking survive.
You know,
and that's going to be hilarious watching
all the liberals who think they're so
fucking smart running from for the
fucking oceans rising, you know,
and they're trying to hang out with
all these gator done fucking people.
All right. That's a
reality show that I, I,
that's not going to have to
be scripted. Um, anyways,
why do I end up with such dark shit?
I always do this when I'm fucking alone.
I just started thinking about the end
of the world and I guess I just saying I
missed my family. All right, I'm going to
stop babbling. Um, God bless all of you.
Enjoy your weekend, your
fucking conch. And I will, uh,
I will check in on you are our guests.
I Dunno.
I'll do another fucking Monday
morning podcast as I do.
I've got to figure out when to do it.
I don't know where I'll be.
I think I'll be in England by then.
Who knows?
Maybe I'll put on a phony accent for you,
Huh?
Failure. Deserve it. Kidding.
Of course. All right. That's
it. Please enjoy the music.
And then we have another half hour of a
Thursday afternoon just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast, greatest
hit episode. All right, that's it.
[inaudible]
Hey, what's going on? It's pilfer and it
is the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
February 21st,
2011 I can't say that.
2011,
2011 fucking tongue gets
stuck to the roof of my mouth.
2011 say,
um,
yes. What is up? It's Sunday afternoon.
I am doing this podcast because I,
I am.
I am committed to finally getting these
things up Monday morning all around the
world. Unless you live in
Japan, but if you live in Japan,
you can't understand what the fuck I'm
saying unless you are a US troop and
you're stationed over there.
At which point I don't know what
the fuck to tell you. All right,
what am I supposed to do?
Nobody in Australia complaints
and there's 17 hours ahead of me.
So standout son.
Um,
I have a big day ahead of me.
The NBA, all star game is, is,
is fucking at the staple center staple
center home of the Los Angeles Lakers and
there are 11 championship banners and
then that one banner with all those ones
from the BBA.
So anyways, you got to be
saying to yourself, hey bill,
you're a big sports fan.
Are you going to go to the game?
Yes I am.
I am going to go to the game.
Can you fucking believe it
kind of came out of nowhere.
All of a sudden I had a hookup.
Somebody came through with a ticket
and I said, apps a Fuckin lutely.
Somebody I know came through with the
fucking ticket for the entire all star
weekend yesterday for the three
point contest and the Dunkin contest.
He said, it starts at five 30 I'm like,
fuck, I'm flying back from New Jersey.
I land right about six and the
guy's like, God, just come on over.
You'll get to catch the last
half fit. I said, great.
I go to get on my flight chief
and he very full flight people.
If you could nudge skin in the aisle,
could you just can't find your seats
so we can expedite the fucking playable
blub, the turmeric. And I'm sitting there
going, let's go. People, fuck, come on,
sit down, sit down. Let's go. I finally
got a hookup. Let's do something.
Let's get this bitch off the ground.
And one of the,
what's the first thing that they say?
I'm praying,
praying for a nice 200 mile an hour
tail wind or whatever the fuck I need to
shave off a half hour, this son
of a bitch. And what do they say?
They say we have a very full flight and
a captain got on and he starts talking
about how there's some fucking biblical
level headwind that's going to slow down
the plane, but we can try and make
a potassium in a different altitude.
Didn't happen.
They always,
they always say that this fucking flight
is going to be about six hours and 15
minutes. All right? It doesn't take,
that takes about five and a half hours
with the usual goddamn headwind. Okay?
But they'd say six hours and 15 minutes
just in case there's a delay, you know,
take off or landing or whatever.
They can still say that they're
on time and if there's no delay,
then they can be like, hey, we got
you in here about 20 minutes early.
Like we can't do the fucking math.
Like we don't know what they're doing.
So it turns out this is fucking insane
headwind and an ends up taking seven
fucking hours to get to lax.
And by the time I landed,
I didn't even want to go.
I didn't even give a shit.
My fucking knees were fucking
behind my shoulders at that point.
Just cramped in there, you know an
idea. I said, fuck gives a shit.
You know that Dunkin contest.
I can watch all of that on Youtube,
but I'm still going to the
fucking game. Um, and I'm psyched.
I've never been to an all star
game before. Never ever, ever.
And I'm psyched to stand there
and look at all the celebrities.
They're going to be there
and all they had bitches. Ha.
I don't want to see the wives.
I want to see that bitches.
I want to see they are gold. Dig and
fucking horse. That's what I want to see.
Fuck the NBA players.
I don't give a shit about them.
Bunch of God Damn Weirdos. You're all
six foot 10. You should be able to dunk.
All right?
And you look weird in street clothes.
You ever see an NBA player in a suit?
You know, we, it looks like that.
It looks like they have like giantism
of something. They don't look right.
They don't look right unless they're in
a tank top and shorts standing next to
another guy who's also
six foot fucking tense.
I don't give a shit about those guys.
They don't give a fuck about me. Right.
I'm there to see the gold digging whores.
I want to see that whole
fucking game going down.
Right? Okay. It's the all star game,
so you know all these celebrities,
they got to bring that bottom bitch to
that one. They got to bring their wife.
They got to bring this serious girlfriend.
That's what the fuck they have to bring.
All right.
Yeah.
She's in the pride,
but on the outside,
little fucking hygiene is trying to
steal a little piece of meat. Right.
That's going to be all the horse.
That's the game. I, that's,
that's the fucking game
I'm going to be watching.
I want to see what
ridiculous fucking outfit.
Yeah.
The gold dig and horror is gonna is
gonna fucking be wearing the length that
she's going to have to go to,
to get this,
these fucking multimillionaires.
To notice him right in front of their
fucking wife. I can't wait. I cannot wait.
You know what? I got an idea how bad it
takes. Some pictures. I'll take some, ah,
I can't do that.
That goes against everything that
I'm about. I can't fucking do.
I can't rat out people. I can't wait.
That's what, that's what I want to see.
I want to see that and absolutely no
defense. You know, one 72, one 68 games.
It's going to be fucking awesome.
I can't wait and uh, and that's it.
So believe it or not, I'm actually in
a great mood. I had an awesome weekend.
I have no funny stories to tell
everything. Everything worked out.
I did the Tarrytown, a music
hall in Tarrytown, New York.
Beautiful,
beautiful,
full, lovely, safe, creepy, scary,
widest fucking town ever. You guys
ever been to West Chester, New York?
There is a level of wealth,
a level of whiteness and a level of
overall piece yet unbelievable fucking
to that part of the country. I can
see I'm tried. I tried to explain,
I was talking about it on stage and
people will laugh and I couldn't tell if
they were just laughing because I was
in that town making fun of it. But like
Terry towns, like ridiculous.
It's like these, these,
I mean you could shoot a period piece
there, some Charles Dickens novel.
If you ever wanted to
turn it into a movie,
you could very easily just remove all
the cars and just dress everybody up.
Like it was a 17 or 18 hundreds and just
have him going up the street and a God
damn horse so it wouldn't be a
fucking prom. Put it this way.
The next town over is sleepy hollow.
All right. Headless Horseman Shit. Okay.
And right next to that
as the Hudson River.
Okay.
All right. And which is eerily quiet
at night and a little bit south.
You've got the Tappan Zee bridge, the
whole thing. It looks like you're on.
You feel like you're on a movie set.
That's what I was joking about,
that everything just felt so wonderful,
peaceful and safe.
And you felt every time
you turned a corner,
you felt that there was just going to
be like a hundred zombies just standing
there and then they'd look at you.
You don't, when they get that,
that excitement that they see fresh
meat and I don't know what happened to
zombies,
but all of a sudden they can run now,
which is pretty fucking awesome unless
you're getting chased by one. Um,
that was the vibe of, of, uh, of
Terry town. But I went in and I did,
did my show. And you've got to understand
like I did that theater like five,
six years ago as part of a tour
for the Montreal comedy festival.
And I was on that tour with like,
like six or seven other comedians.
So all I got to do was like 15 minutes.
And I remember I was excited then
to be doing it. And you know,
you start thinking like,
man,
am I ever going to be able to play this
place on my own? Was fucking awesome.
I showed up and the place was
packed and then the next night was,
uh, the count Basie theater
in Red Bank, New Jersey.
And that place was gigantic. And
the second, you know, we booked it.
I was paranoid that they're going to have
to cancel it or I don't think it only
be like half fucking full. And that one
ended up fucking selling out. And, uh,
so I just want to thank everybody and
creepy ass Tarrytown, sleepy hollow,
Westchester County who
showed up to my gig. Um,
and everybody out in New Jersey now,
people fucking sleep on
New Jersey by the way.
Okay.
You know,
because all they do is they come out of
Manhattan and they jump on the Jersey
turnpike and they see all those
chemical fucking plants and uh,
and they just think it's, it's a
shit hole. But I'm telling you,
there's some absolutely gorgeous
parts of it. And Red Bank,
New Jersey was one of
them. Like, I saw you.
Have you ever seen what a $20 million
home looks like? You know, live.
I've never seen it. It's, it's,
it's like these fucking people
live in houses as big as schools
and you know, and as much as they were
and as much as I was in awe of them,
I just remember thinking,
how could you possibly do,
have done anything remotely
legal to get that fucking house,
you know, I'm telling you, I swear to God,
I bet 90% of them were
bankers and people in finance.
I'm telling you.
And then the other will be like the,
Oh that guy created a then the mutant
Ninja turtles for something huge.
But other than that,
if you're just a regular fucking person,
the only way to make that
kind of fucking money
is you've got to be in banking.
Okay.
Fucking genius. Whoever came up with
the idea of a bank, hey everybody,
you guys work all week and then you
give you money to me. All right.
Then I'll pull it all together and I'll
loan it back to yet interests and then
you give me more money on that while
you continue to give me all your other
money every fucking week.
Don't worry, I'll keep it safe.
You piece of Shit,
mother Fucker fucking kidding me.
Well, how do you justify, how do
you earn enough fucking money?
Yeah,
I could see if Derek Jeter had one
of those houses. I get it. I get it.
He fucking shows up to a stadium
and 60,000 people show up.
What did they go? What
happened if they said, hey,
a bankers giving a
lecture at Yankee Stadium.
How many fucking people you think
would show up fucking asshole?
He probably couldn't even fill
up the stress factory. You know?
That's what I swear to God. That's,
that's, that's my feeling when, when I,
the few times that I've gotten
into those types of areas,
I drive by them and I am an absolute
fucking awe of the level of wealth.
And then that's immediately what I think.
Like there's no fucking way,
there's no legal fucking way to do this.
You know, take it from
me, take it from me.
I'm doing all right now. You know,
selling out theaters. Let me you,
you should see the laws that they have
to make sure that I don't get rich.
They are just dead, taken a fucking
machete to my knees right now.
When we do an impression of my,
of me talking to my account
and every quarter what Joe,
you gotta be, you know something
to this fucking country. That's,
that's 0.3 seconds.
But I get it. I get it. We're
fighting to fucking wars.
Somebody's got to pay for it
and can be those rich country.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Anyways,
fuck was I talking about? Yeah. You
know what it's like, it's like that,
that president over there in Egypt,
you know,
he was like a bank.
He had all their fucking money and it
was just sitting there. He took it.
Of course he took it, you know
something. I'm not even mad at bankers.
I'm not even fucking mad at him because
I think, well, I don't know. I can't,
I can't say money.
That isn't the thing that gets me going.
Women, I would say that you got to
pick your weakness. Some people,
your weaknesses, money, some
people your weaknesses. Power.
Mine is the fucking Bra.
Okay.
I'll tell you right now,
if making people laugh ever gets me
to the level of being a dictator,
there is no fucking way I'm going to be
able to remain faithful. I will have,
who was, do you understand me? People I
will have fucking who was listening to me.
I'm going to the fucking NBA All
star game tonight. All right. And um,
it's,
I'm more excited to see the level of gold
dig and fucking whore that's going to
show up the temptresses.
I can't wait.
I cannot fucking wait to see how high up
you have to Jackie a fucking ass up to
get noticed at the all star game.
Cause you know,
every horror out there is she's
going, what? The fucking four,
five inch Goddamn stilettos.
Ah,
walking down those, those, those fucking,
you know, they're all going to be sitting,
you know where to gold digging whores.
Sit. The wives sit court side, they sit,
they sit in a group.
You've ever noticed that they all
keep the wives all you know, together.
It's a very smart move by the men,
you know,
cause you've got a
bunch of women together.
Eventually they're just going
to be running their mouths.
They're not gonna be
paying attention to shit.
I don't think I'll be doing that shit
while the fucking games going on.
They don't give a shit, right.
I'd say the gold digging whores,
I'm going to say that they're going to
start at about row about 20 maybe 21 it's
a more believable number,
right? 20 was to even, you know,
row 23 that's where they're
going to start. All right,
and that's going to be like
the gold digging whores,
gold digging whore. You know what I
mean? Like the quarterbacks, quarterback,
the comic's comic,
the whores whore is going to be at
the NBA All star game already banging
somebody.
Yeah.
Already hooked up.
She's going to be about road 20 right?
She's already going to guilt it.
Somebody down there,
somebody connected that you know,
how come your wife is sitting
seven rows in front of me. Hey,
I got to do what I got to fucking do
and don't worry. I'll make it up to you.
So she already has something shiny
coming her fucking way. All right.
And then you go back. You get what
you go it while staple San Jose.
Weird where it's kind of the
haves the have nots, you know,
see if he get to the upper deck, those
are like the open miker horse. All right?
That's someone who just
fucking blew somebody in a
ticket booth to get up to the
300 fucking level. All right? So
what they gonna do is they're basic,
you're going to be dressed
hot for ah, you know, I dunno.
They're going to be update
with the fucking uh, potato
skin. Eaton Sports Bar Guy,
right?
The season ticket holder assumption.
I don't know what the fuck I'm consulting
is kind of unraveling all I know.
It's just going to be a bunch of
fucking horse down there and I can't,
I can't wait to look at them.
No, I've, I've come to this level
in life where I really, I'm,
I don't judge people. I know I'm saying
horrors and gold digging a I, you know,
I know I'm saying that Shit, but I'm
not in a judgmental way. The same thing.
I don't judge that. The, the,
the fucking piece of shit.
I guess that's judgemental. But you
know, whatever. I'm a piece of shit.
The piece of shit guy who was a
running shit over there in Egypt,
you know I get why he stole
all that fucking money
cause it was right there.
You know
is right fucking there.
I mean,
until you are in that
position where you're,
you're at that level of temptation
till you faced it and passed that test.
You can't judge that guy.
Can you imagine that?
Just a mountain of cash just sitting
right to the righty. A lazy boy.
You're like a big bowl of fucking
m and m's and you guys out there.
I got your little fucking m and
m's right next to your TV chair.
How many of those deed and night,
you know,
you ever tell yourself this
is the last handful get done.
You can go right back for more.
You have a get it so fucking,
you know you're doing that thing where
you're making the fist and then you'd get
fucking dropping them out of the bottom
of your fist. You know, like some fucking,
I dunno what, like some goddamn guppy
feeding at the top of a fish tank.
Uh, we're all gluttonous assholes and
I'm, I'm, I'm right up there with them.
I read with the fucking point was,
I'm just telling you I'm excited.
I'm going to this fucking game.
Uh, that's 17 minutes, 17 minutes.
How many fucks was that sir?
Um,
all right,
let's get on with the podcast here.
I want to thank everybody seriously who
came out to the, uh, Terry town. Um,
I keep forgetting the music hall and,
uh, the count Basie theater and a,
I'm going to keep writing jokes because
that was unbelievably motivating.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I'm gonna
try to do that every, every year.
Absolutely phenomenal
fucking, uh, experience.
I have nothing bad to say about any of
it. And last week people, I told you a,
if you want to become part of this
podcast, if you would like to participate,
if you'd like to comment on any
fucked up thing that I said,
if you'd like to introduce a new topic
or add to the topics that exist or just
vent.
We,
I have a new email streamline and getting
all the podcasts emails to one email
so I don't miss any of the good ones.
Is bill@themmpodcast.com once again,
bill@themmpodcast.com.
And if you could do us a favor,
if you could just in the
title, um, in the, uh,
in the subject line, could
you just stick, you know,
under what category is going to fist
fit if you have overrated, underrated,
if you want some advice. Um, is
it racist? Your country sucks too.
Um, anything, anything you want to, you
have any youtube videos of the week,
anything? Just just right. Obviously
overrated. Youtube is it racist,
right in the subject line of really helped
us to kind of streamline them cause I
actually have somebody now who's gathering
all of them and just sends them to me
one email and then you know,
I just read through all of them.
I picked the best ones, the ones
that I respond to. So once again,
you email it bill@themmpodcast.com.
Uh,
and that is it.
And the official podcast of the Monday
morning podcast is www.themlmpodcast.com
we have all the youtube videos.
Anything that I talk about,
pictures of theaters, anything I'm
talking about gold digging, who is,
we'll have pictures and that type of
shit so he can follow along at work right
before you slump over
and die in your cubicle.
Um,
all right.
I got a little backlash
this past week from um,
from a number of things. One from, is
it racist and another number from, uh,
the two drink minimum. Let's start
with two drink minimum first. Um,
last week someone was talking about the
two drink minimum, uh, why they have that,
a comedy clubs.
And I was trying to explain that that's
basically how the comedy club makes
money. So this guy says, Bill, as
I listened to the podcast today,
I must disagree with your
diatribe on the two drink minimum.
You don't you love that rather than
my opinion, it becomes a diatribe.
I knew a diatribe means,
but that just sounds like he made it seem
like I was going on and on and on. Um,
I agree.
That comedy club,
I agree that comedy clubs need to
make money. Well, thank you sir.
Thank you for extending me
that fucking olive branch.
I agree that sometimes they
promise certain payouts.
Okay. I wasn't asking you to
agree with it. That's how it is.
But the two drink minimum is the
equivalent of every other company's hidden
charges.
If the club needs to make money,
add $20 to the price of a fucking ticket.
People that don't drink have a real
issue being forced to buy drinks because
some clown can't manage
his business any tighter.
Whatever happened to truth in advertising,
tell me up front what the entertainment
bill is going to cost me regarding,
all right, whatever happened to
truth in advertising. Um, sir,
if you can tell me an era when there
was ever any truth in advertising.
Um,
I will give you a box of free DVDs.
There's never been any
truth in advertising,
and that includes you when you went out
to bars and you were trying to get your
Dick sucked the way you made your job
sound a lot more important than it was.
All right? So get off your
fucking high horse right there.
That's the first high horse you have to
get off. All right? In a nice while you,
it's like you're fucking driving.
You ever see the Budweiser Clydesdale
fucking thing? You know that?
I don't know what it does. The stage
coach for the guy who owns Budweiser,
I never really understood what the fuck
that thing was supposed to be. But uh,
you have a team of Clydesdale
high horses here. All right.
The fact that you have to state that up,
God damn business needs to make money and
that they actually promised to pay the
ax. I don't understand those
points. Um, and just, okay,
first of all,
he's saying that a two drink minimum is
the equivalent of every other company's
hidden charges. There's nothing
hidden about the two drink minimum.
It's written on the fucking ticket.
It's on a sign inside the
club as you're walking in,
it's announced before the show.
Everything two drink minimum,
they actually have called comedy should
teach shows on TV to trunk two drink
minimum. They used to be a show called
two drink minimum. You know what I mean?
It's like you'd saying that there's some
sort of hidden thing that a fire engine
is red. You go into a club, there's
a two drink minimum. All right?
What I think is really
going on here is you,
you don't understand the business
of running a comedy club.
All right?
Okay.
The, the, it's what? I don't understand
why you're saying, why don't you,
why don't you, uh, people that
don't drink have a real itch.
Everybody drinks, sir. Everybody drinks.
Okay.
All right. You don't drink. You don't
drink at all. You don't drink water.
You don't drink soda,
you don't drink at all.
You don't have to buy a
drink that has alcohol in it,
but you have to buy a drink.
All right?
And you're getting mad at
the wrong fucking people.
You're getting mad at the club because
they're forcing you to buy drinks.
Why do you think that is?
Why do you think he cut
the club owners greedy?
The reason why they force you to buy
drinks is because of the amount of fucking
tightwads that show up to clubs and
go, can I have a water? Two straws.
Police. That's the problem. All right.
See,
back in the day that probably wasn't a
two drink minimum because back in the day
the artists used to get unbelievably
fucked by the promoter, believe it or not,
back in the day.
This is like before free agency in sports.
Back in the day believer in or
not when a band, a comedian,
any sort of entertainer,
went to a venue to perform.
The promoter got 80% of the door.
Okay.
And the artists got 20%
okay.
All right.
But because of the brilliance and the
balls of Peter Grant with led Zeppelin,
as far as I know,
I'm giving him credit.
He's the first guy I read that finally
went up to the and said, listen mate,
they come in here to look at the
fucking building. Alright? Yes.
Silly cunt that coming here to see fucking
led Zeppelin. I know it's a brutal,
brutal British accent, but
he was the guy going, listen,
nobody gives a fuck about your building.
I could stick these guys in
any fucking building out here.
They're going to sell out because
they coming to see the band.
So he was the guy who said,
listen,
we get 80% you get fucking 20% all right,
so the promoter has to make his fucking
money and he makes money by selling food
and drinks. All right. That's how it is.
But the problem is is people will go in
there and they won't fucking buy drinks
or they won't buy food.
They'll go in there and
they will sit there and they
will sip on a fucking water.
That's why there is a two drink minimum,
which is advertised on the fucking ticket.
It is advertised.
They have it on a sign before
you even fucking walk in there.
The call up the comedy club,
they say there is a two drink minimum.
This show is 21 and older.
What the two drink minimum.
I've heard that maybe 40 million times
in my comedy career there was no sort of
false advertising going on here,
sir.
All right. That is why they
have to make money, dude.
Do you know how much money it
costs to run a fucking club?
Do you know much money? It cost to get
a liquor license. You want to people,
you have to grease the amount of taxes
you have to pay the amount you have to
pay and fucking rent.
All of that bullshit.
You know what you don't,
I know a guy opened up a fucking
theater and there was these union guys.
Alright. And to change the sign,
he had to hire two union guys,
one guy to go up the ladder,
one guy to hold the fucking ladder
and a cop to stand there and make sure
everything was fine.
It was costing them like 1500 bucks to
put up and this week come down and check
out Bob Saget or whatever
the fuck was there.
So he had to sit there and lobby with
politicians and lobby with all these
fucking people and try and go around
unions and all this fucking horseshit just
so we could get a sign out front that he
could change electronically from inside
the building.
Okay.
Do you want to stay on that fifth 1500
bucks a week times 52 weeks a year?
That's just, if you just change
it once, forget about this guy.
The way he had it running,
he had a musical act and a comedy act and
then a musical act every fucking week.
So it's three times a week.
That's what, 3040 500 bucks.
That's like what, 250 fucking grand a
year to get a guy to change letters.
On a fucking sign. Okay. It costs money
to run. Oh God. Damn business. All right.
I don't know what else to tell you,
but you're getting mad at clubs for
having two drink minimums. It's,
it's, you know, it's not
the club. It's not the club.
It's all,
it's the tight fuck sitting next to you.
Who's going to bring cheezits in and a
little butter knife to spread his cheese
on and that shit, you know, I don't
fucking stay home. I don't know what to
tell you. I don't know what to tell you.
Uh,
what else?
What are the backlash like? Oh, I
got backlash this week on the, uh,
the fuck was it? Is it racist? I went
back and forth with this fucking guy,
which was hilarious.
This guy was,
he wrote that guy last week who
wrote the thing where he said a bill.
Older Asian is racist as
shit. I'm sorry, but it is.
So I wrote him back where I was like,
well dude,
you kind of have to elaborate
on your point. And number two,
why are you apologizing?
That's kind of a pet peeve of mine.
I hate when someone disagree with you
and then they apologize. I'm sorry,
but you're wrong. It's like, dude,
you're not, you're not sorry.
Why are you saying you're sorry?
What are you sorry about?
You're not fucking sorry.
Stop saying you're sorry.
So this guy goes on and on and on,
and he proceeds to basically say that
I was playing on Asian stereotypes,
um,
and that,
and I had preconceived
notions about Asians and all
this type of shit, you know,
and I don't give a fuck if you
are just joking. That is racist.
I don't give a fuck how you meant it.
It's fucking race.
All that psycho shit.
And then he proceeds to prove
his point by then hitting me.
I Dunno what he,
the rest of his fucking email,
he was trying to give me examples
that my preconceived notions,
my alleged preconceived notions about
Asians was fucked up as he then dumps up
all his preconceived notions about white
people. He goes really of the ages,
the only bad drivers.
What about all those rich
white kids denting their
dad's Mercedes on the regular
fucking Hilarious, you know? All right.
And then I just asked him to name who
those rich white kids worth because you
know, I hung out with a letter.
What white kids growing up,
all white kids and none of their,
our dads had fucking Russ.
Who are these rich white kids, sir?
Where did you meet these rich white kids?
Where you and your younger brother with
the fucking kidney disease adopted by a
rich white man? Is that how you
ran into all these rich white kids?
You're fucking generalizing. You're
doing the exact same horse shit. So,
but it ended up being a great debate. And
this is, this is what, this is what I've,
I've, I've come to realize about
jokes when it comes to race. I think,
I could be wrong here, but I think
they threw this three categories.
When you do it,
when you joke in a racial way,
it can either a be straight up,
funny B be offensive or
c be racist and it all,
and there's a bunch of variables that
play into it and it plays in to the intent
of the person. If your intent
is not to be fucking racist,
what you said I believe is not racist.
What it is at that point is offensive.
You made a joke,
you thought it was going to be funny,
but people took it a different way.
They didn't find it funny.
Okay.
They're saying it's racist.
You acknowledge it's just
fucking around and it's like,
well at that then it
becomes offensive I think.
All right,
and then it also comes down to your
relationship because if you know you'll
fucking white and somebody else is
black or whatever and your friends,
the level of being offended gets
pushed way down the Goddamn street.
You know, to the point. Sometimes
if other people are listening,
they can't believe what the fuck the
two of you are saying to each other.
But I still maintain, it comes down
to intent now that older Asian,
Oh and and the social situation,
all the region of just fucking around.
It's a joke. It's not racist
because I don't have any fucking
bad feelings about agents. It's just
something that's a funny fucking game.
I came up with driving and
traffic after I saw a pattern,
I kept getting cut off and it just seemed
that 80% of the fucking time it was
either some old due to some Asian dude.
So as a joke,
I started playing that game with my
girl. What do you want? Older Asian,
what do you got? Put your money
on the table just fucking around.
Now obviously if I'm doing
that outside of the car,
I'm gonna fucking offense.
I'm going to offend somebody.
But it's still not racist because
I don't mean it that way, you know?
I know a lot of people are going to
fucking disagree with that, but I truly,
you can't tell me what the fuck. I mean,
I know what I'm thinking. You know?
Does that fucking May, I don't
know. I don't fucking know.
But in the same thing is
that that older Asian thing,
Barack Obama couldn't be in the middle
of doing the state of the union go,
we're going to get turned into country
around, we're going to do this.
We'll do that. And you
know what? You know what,
I like to play in the back
whenever my limo gets cut up,
I play this game called older Asian,
you know,
that's even then if he's
just fucking around,
I don't think that's racist is incredibly
irresponsible and would be taken that
way. And at the very least it would be
unbelievably fucking offensive. But I,
that's what I think.
You guys tell me what you think.
I think if you just fucking around,
if you don't mean it in a malicious way,
it's, it's not racist.
You can be ignorant.
You can offend fucking people in
that type of stuff. But you know,
I really don't think that me playing
a game called older Asian is,
is racist.
Like some fucking guy in the clan going,
we need to get these
people out of the country.
They're beasts and that type of shit.
All right. And I know what you can say.
Well, do the two, the Dutch, so you, what
you're doing is a lighter form now. No,
I'm not. No, I'm not. You're an
oversensitive fucking cunt. All right?
And you're so far to the fucking left.
You're actually doing like this.
Mccarthyism, bleeding heart horse shit,
go fuck yourself. Lighten the fuck up.
Okay.
Like when when I a black
comic or somebody's giving
me shit that white people
can't dunk a basketball or they,
they can't fucking dance, you know,
depending on how they say,
if they say it in a mean enough way,
I could get offended. I maybe could
get offended. But first of all,
my honestly going to sit there
and act like generally speaking,
white dudes can fucking dance.
Well,
white people in general or that would
dunk it a basketball how many six foot 11
fucking guys have I seen
two and a half step and they just
fucking dislocate their shoulder,
hitting the ball in the front of the
fucking rim. You know, I think, you know,
I think a lot of people they don't have,
they don't have a fucking sense
of humor either. So, uh, I dunno.
I think that guy last week at the Tony
Gwynn game, that's fucking hilarious.
Yeah.
That game that other guy played
where he sits there saying, you know,
it turns his back to the news and he
hears the crime when he tries to guess the
race is fucking hilarious.
This guy had three heads in his
refrigerator, crazy ass white guy,
crazy ass cracker or whatever.
Like that's, it's funny.
Okay.
Am I saying anything funny this week?
I feel like it just been ranting for
the past 20 fucking minutes. All right,
let's, let's plow ahead here. Oh, some
advice. All right. Advice Bill. Uh,
I've heard you mentioned a few times
that when you dedicated yourself to
following your dream,
you, uh, is a comedian.
You sacrificed everything to throw
yourself completely into comedy.
And then you usually say that on some
level it was easier for you to put
everything on the line because you were
young and it didn't have a lot to risk.
I'm 37 years old with a wife and two
young boys who are ages four and six year
ago I decided that I
wanted to be a comedian.
I've been doing open mikes consistently
for a year and I feel like I have real
potential.
I know it takes a lot of time to get good.
My problem is I can't
pay this month's rent.
I'm scared to get a book better
fulltime job because it will take,
um,
Mr Away.
Okay.
It'll take me away from my dream.
Little Typo there.
When you are older and have
responsibilities like kids and a wife,
how do you justify taking
risks to go for your dream?
All right, dude. All right.
This is a rough one for me to give
you advice on because I had never,
I've never been in that situation.
And also I never want
to talk somebody out of,
of doing what you want to do.
You should definitely keep doing standup
if that's what your heart's telling you
to do.
But as a man,
you cannot have a wife and kids and
not be able to pay the rent. All right?
Um,
you need to get a better full time job
and you just need to fucking work harder
and be more efficient when
you go out to the club.
If you've been hanging out a little
bit, don't hang out at all. And um,
okay.
You know.
Okay.
It's what you're trying to do is not
impossible, but I will tell you this.
You can't, who's kitten hope? All right?
The number one job of a man is to fucking
provide you have to provide for your
family. If you're not,
you know, I, you know,
I, I don't want to say
this, but a lot they, you,
the women look at you like
you're fucking useless.
Okay.
All right.
That's like them without a fucking vagina.
And I hate to reduce them as sex objects,
but that's just how we view you
fucking with you. But seriously, all
right, you have to provide, okay.
This is the thing I think, you
know, if your wife is cool,
she will understand that you
want to make this transition,
but you have to make it
as smooth as possible.
You can't be in a situation where you're,
where you can't pay the fucking rent.
All right? So, um,
I would get a better day job
if you had to at this time
so you can pay the fucking rent.
And then you can burn it at both ends and
do your stand up at night or whatever.
Right? And then eventually when you
start getting paid gigs with that,
then you can start to phase out the
fucking day job. All right? But uh,
if I was you, I would sit down and
have a heart to heart with your wife.
So she gets where your head's at,
you know, and just tell her, look,
I really want to do this, but I understand
my job as a man as I have to provide.
So I, I've, this won't happen again.
Okay.
Yeah. You know, you gotta have, you got
up, you got to pay the fucking pills,
you know,
you got it.
Pay The fucking bills. It's
just, it's your job as a guy.
It really is.
I don't give a fuck about all is equal
rights in fucking independent women puts
your fucking titties
in the air or whatever.
How are the fuck that Goddamn song
goes? Oh right. Providing is our job.
That's our fucking job. We
have to, you have to do it.
Wait, you have to fucking do it. You know?
What are you fucking Steadman, you know,
I guess that's okay if you, if you,
if your, your your chick is Oprah,
speaking of which,
you haven't seen some Oprah's houses.
I became fascinated with that when I did
that red bank and I was just looking at
those fucking houses,
the level of wealth and I just
started typing in Bill Gates' house,
Oprah's house and just like the most,
the richest people I could fucking
think of. Like Jesus Christ,
Jesus Christ, m and m's house
looked up his for some reason.
Um, they're unbelievable. These,
first of all they always like in them
surrounding them was always like a forest.
Like they don't even have this show.
Rich Dad have neighbors. Some of them,
some of them they've lived, you
know, crowded areas like Miami beach.
But some of these fucking people,
okay.
Like m and m's house looked like a,
like a,
I don't even know how to describe it.
It looked like a house that got,
looks like an optical illusion.
Like it was a house. And then
you give a c, like in a movie,
like where all of a sudden
a guy just gets a hunchback.
That's what his house looked like.
It was a house. And then boom,
there's another part of the house. And
then, then another house, he's was like,
he just took like these 20 fucking
houses and just stuck them all together.
That'd be a great house to have if,
if, if you were wanted by the law,
you know what I mean? You could literally
hide out in your own fucking house,
take by it by at least another two and
a half weeks of freedom by the time they
fucking found you. You know, I don't know.
I don't know what the Hell I'm saying.
Um, so anyways, do that. That's, that's a
real tough situation. I hope you work out.
Don't give up on your
dream, but, uh, you know,
your wife is going to be way
more supportive if, if, if you,
if you pay in the God damn, you gotta
pay the bills. Got To pay the bills.
All right, here we go.
Next one. Hey, Bill. Uh,
asked for advice a couple of
months ago about a friend of mine.
This was another brutal one.
Yeah.
But a friend of mine who's girlfriend
was having a kid and I was suspicious
about whether or not,
um,
it was his because he had gone and gotten
checked twice to see if he could have
kids. And the doctors said No. Oh, I
remember this guy. Remember that one?
The doctor said this guy,
he got checked twice.
He said he couldn't have kids and all
of a sudden his girl was pregnant and
there was questions about her
being faithful. I remember this,
I remember this well this is the
update of this. He said, well,
about five months into the
pregnancy she miscarried.
So the problem kind of solved itself,
but it was a terrible thing to happen.
Now they are living together and I'm
still pretty positive she was cheating on
him and he's hanging onto the relationship
now through some sort of guilt
because of the lost child.
It just feels like my friend got one
pulled over on him and I really want to
talk to him about it, but I can't
find a good way to do it. Uh,
you podcasts rules and I hope you come
to Edmonton sometime. It'll comic strip,
right? The comic strip in Edmonton. I'll
make my way up there at some point. Um,
through that is a brutal,
brutal, brutal, brutal situation.
And uh,
it all depends on how you feel.
Are you going to be able to live with
yourself if you just say, listen,
this kid is just a moron. He's my
friend, but he's a fucking moron.
Cause that is an option. You
know, the Goodfellas moment,
you know, when he, he, uh,
they tell that joke in Italian and de
Niro says, what does it mean in, in pet?
She goes, it means he's, he's
content to be a jerk. You know,
what am I going to say?
My wife two times meet that joke
basically about a guy who knows his wife's
fucking around on him and he just doesn't,
he just looks the other way.
He's content to be a jerk.
So that's what your friend is right now.
I know this emotions involved, so
does there is hope for them, but
you know,
he's,
he's fucking himself over.
So this deal,
if you can live with yourself and just
say, this guy's contend to be a jerk,
I'm not going to get in the fucking
middle of this because there's so many
obvious red flags here and this kid
is just choosing to ignore them.
Um, you could just say, fuck it.
He's content to be a fucking idiot,
but if you're not going to be
able to live with yourself,
then I would just sit down and
talk to him. All right? And,
um,
hopefully listens to you.
And if not any stops being your friend,
um, there's nothing you
can fucking do about that.
And I got a feeling probably
seven or eight years from now,
you might get a phone call him
saying, you know what, you are right,
but those are impossible situations.
Jesus Christ.
How the fuck would I handle that?
I would, uh, I would say
something. You know what? I would,
I would definitely say something, but, uh,
I don't know how to do that, to be honest
with you. I the fuck what I was say.
I say, listen, you know, I'm friends
with you. We've been friends a long time.
That's when yes, when you buddy
knows something fucked ups coming.
Let's see. We've been friends a long time,
right pat? A lot of good times. Right.
You know,
you know,
you know that I've always been there
for you and I never tried to steer your
wrong. Right? Like I
think your girlfriend,
is it too time and
yeah.
How do you say that?
I would just rip the bandaid
off. Just say, listen,
there's something I have to talk to
you about with friends and as a friend.
All right,
I can't stop thinking about this.
And it would kill me to not bring
this up to you. I have to do this.
I'm not trying to be malicious.
I'm doing this because you're my friend.
And then I would just
say, look, ah, Jesus,
I just had it and I already forgot
how fucking difficult to say is.
I would just be, it's
fucking ridiculous. Look,
you told me you couldn't have kids.
You went to the doctor twice.
You got tested.
They said you couldn't have kids yet.
This girl somehow got fucking pregnant.
Don't say fuck there yet.
Your, your, your girl
somehow got pregnant. Okay.
Then you just sort of stare at them.
I don't know where to go from there.
All right.
My guts telling me that that
wasn't your fucking kid. See,
that's a hard one to that one.
That kid you just fucking cried
over that didn't get born.
I don't think it was yours. Anyways.
Ah, Jesus, dude, this is fucking brutal.
Brutal.
Um,
I would do,
this is what I would do.
I would do what I'm doing right now into
a mirror and just keep correcting it as
you go the same way I said,
okay. Don't say fuck there.
And then you back it up again and
just somehow figured a way out.
A way to say that I think your
girlfriend is a whore. Uh,
I don't think that she's being,
I don't think you're,
I don't think the woman that you're
with has been a 100% honest with you.
Yeah.
And I don't think,
okay.
That she has been 100% faithful.
And my gut was telling me that that
wasn't your kid. See, that's brutal.
Taking it to there. All right. I think
you need to get out of this relationship.
I mean, I don't do it. I don't know how
to do it. I don't know how to fuck. Yeah,
you stumped me. Stumped the Swami. I know
now like I know everything obviously,
but uh, I usually can come
up with some sort of angle.
I don't know what the fuck to tell you.
Okay.
Um, but for whatever you
do, don't write it down.
Don't put it in a letter
cause he'll probably show it
to her and then, then, uh,
then it'll just be brutal. The
fuck that. Don't, don't do that.
Just a huge, that's a, uh, yeah.
I don't want to tell you, dude,
that's a fucking brutal one.
Jesus. Does it work to just
say it? Listen, man, you're
best. We're best friends,
right? We could say anything to each
other. Yeah. I think your girlfriend, ah,
fuck somebody else without a condom and
got pregnant instead it was yours and
it's such a fucking psycho cunt that she
was about ready to let you take on the
responsibility and invest
that sort of time, your life.
She was content to throw away your
fucking life because she can't keep her
fucking legs on the ground and her
panties up around a fucking waste.
Do you understand me?
She's a fucking whore.
All right.
You went to two fucking doctors and
they said you can't get pregnant, dude.
How dumb are you?
Get your fucking head out of her fucking
vagina. Wake up. It's not your kid.
All right. That was God. God gave you
a fucking Mulligan. He gave you a pass.
All right? They had go.
You want to get, oh Jesus.
You want to get fucking religious about
it? Get out of the goddamn relationship.
Stop being such a fucking pussy.
Okay.
Leave her
cry about it for fucking six weeks.
Whatever you gotta do.
Go join a fucking gym and get on with
your fucking life and start wearing a
condom.
All right.
Now I know that team that we saw in the
first half is not the fuck attain that.
I know.
Yeah,
we got another 30 minutes of fucking
football and I want you to get out there.
It proved to me that you could play
and I got the way I know he could play.
That's what you do. You go anywhere we
go. It took me a minute to work it out.
You go fucking Vince
Lombardi. Grab, grab, grab,
nobody tackling.
Okay.
She's a fucking whore. You got to go
like dad. Got to build up. You got
to start slow. You got to start slow. Oh,
my years of looking at relationships.
I don't think I have ever
in my life seen a woman.
So pull the fucking wool a pubes over
somebody's fucking eyes like I did and
that first half.
Okay.
You know what I saw up there? I saw both
jet, just some, I don't know how to do it.
I'm out. I don't know what to tell
you. I don't know what to tell you.
Tell that fucking kid. He needs to make
some halftime adjustments. All right,
pull the rip cord. Get the
fuck out of that jeep. I
see these, these, these are the
things they, they don't, they don't,
they don't talk about these kinds of,
of, of women on, on those real shows.
They'll show women like that on Jerry
Springer and everyone looks like a retard,
so nobody gives a fuck. Right? But they
won't show those kinds of women on those,
those real sort of issue shows when that,
just always talking about
guys who beat their women,
which they're horrible fucking people
and they should talk about them.
But why don't they ever talk about horse?
You know,
the only time they talk about whores
is just when they try to figure out why
there were a whore.
You know,
dad didn't stick around fucking uncle
dental, Domo, you know, whatever.
They always got a fucking reason. I
always got a God damn excuse. You know,
maybe they're just horse.
Do you ever think of that?
I think there's already women out.
There is a woman out down when
I want to know this. Okay.
This is totally anonymous and I'm not
judging you because I'm a male whore
myself. All right, I want to know this.
Is there a woman out there with dad
stuck around? You had a great family.
You weren't touched in any funny way.
You went to school,
you know you are girl scouts,
you did all the right things,
but you just love Dick.
And not only do you love Dick,
you love a bunch of different decks
and you are in a relationship,
but every once in a while you just
got to go out and go bag somebody else
because you're fucking bored basically.
Are you wired like a man?
That's what I want to know.
Okay. And you can be totally
honest. Let's examine,
let's examine that because I don't even
think it's fair to just brand them all
horse.
I don't,
I think some of them are raw,
actually really intelligent and they've
actually sat and contemplated it,
you know? Or you know, done.
What I've done is justify
their piece of shit moves.
Okay.
Oh, you know something. This is the time
when I really should just have a guest.
I don't have a guest. I got to have more
guests on this fucking podcast. What,
what do what do, what do you, what
do you want from me? All right.
You guys want some youtube
videos for this week? Huh?
Have you slumped over and
you cubicles lift yet?
Have you done that with five minutes
left and you fucking day. All right.
You two videos for the, um, the
truth about Facebook privacy.
I actually haven't a
chance to watch this yet.
This was suggested to me by somebody close
to me, so I just put that on there. I,
here's a go. When fireworks fail,
sky's shoots off one. That should,
it should have gone on after
the fucking Boston pops.
And he basically shoots it off in his
own neighborhood and for some reason it
goes off about, oh, I don't know
about maybe 30, 35 feet in the air,
a bunch of houses around.
Um, here's another good one.
Angry skateboarder.
Here's a hockey one.
Blonde Jaeger is in Jaromir Jaeger
and a band called a mute math.
Great musicians, great albums, albums,
and they have a fucking insane drummer.
Oh. Speaking of which people,
speaking of which, um,
I've been taking my drumming to a new
level, to a brand new fucking for me.
For me, I still suck,
but after plateauing, I,
uh, I just sort of, I
got fucking add, right.
As you can tell from my podcast, I, if
you notice that I start to make a point,
then something else reminds me
of something else. And then yeah,
maybe I'll drive over to the left for
a while. You know, I can't sit still,
I can't focus unless,
uh,
unless something really fucked up
is happening. That's the only thing.
Something really fucked up has to be
happening before you will get 100% of my
attention, you know? I don't know why,
but that's how it is. So,
uh, with my playing drums,
I'm the same way.
I'm always learning,
trying to learn five different
things at the same fucking time.
Okay.
You know, I'll do this for like
three minutes, then I'll do this,
but three minutes, I'll do this for two
minutes and then, and then I'll fuck it.
You know?
And then I have three new things that
I'm trying to learn and rather than just
learning one and getting
it down, I don't. And uh,
it's something I've known for a while.
I watched this guy, Mike Johnston,
who has these great
lessons. Any, he had this,
he basically mapped out
on how to practice. He,
she'd show you something and it was,
it was pattern.
You get the pattern down and then you
bring it up to speed and then you'd move
it all around the kit. So it's
just pattern speed, movement, a, B,
c one, two, three could,
couldn't have got any more basic,
but my fucking add,
I couldn't fucking do it.
So I finally decided I was fucking sick.
Okay.
I was sick of this shit. So I just
decided to focus on a couple of things.
And one of them was that Joe Joe May or
fucking thing with your bass drum foot.
It's something I saw Steve Gadd do a,
this is really for drum heads here.
Steve Gadd do is up close video a long
time ago and I sat down and I fuck with
that thing after borderline messing
with it for a year and a half,
I sat down for like three days in a row
and religiously worked on it and was
blown away by how much faster I got my
foot as far as being able to do three
hits in a row because I'm Ah,
who's kidding who and he's Zeppelin
fans out there. There's two licks,
three licks that I've been
trying to get down. Okay.
I finally be able to get the good
times, bad times, 16th note, triplets.
I can do those fucking things up to
speed. I can play good times, bad times,
but when he does to three in a row,
like that lick he does on a,
I can't quit you bay when he does the
three in a row there and out on the tiles
is a lick in there where I think,
I think I'm hearing three
and then the want and song,
which is a big debate on how
this is so fucking insane.
I'm really going to lose
a lot of listeners here,
but there's a big debate on how the
fuck he plays that. Does he pay bone,
the debt, that debt or done
that? The debt that the debt,
I think he does three after the
snare [inaudible] on the two. Uh, so,
so fucking stupid.
Why am I talking about this anyways?
What that Joe Joe Mayor Shit.
Okay.
They play that at about 101 hundred
two beats per minute. But that Joe,
Joe Mayor thinks I can play that lick
with the three hits on the bass drum after
the snare onto, I can play that
at 90 beats per minute. Um,
permit. Yeah, I can play
it at data at this point.
So I'm within fucking striking
distance of that after, you know,
fucking with this thing for a year
and a half, finally just sitting down.
Um, and if drummers out there
wasn't any sort of advice,
I can show you what I did because I,
I'm just really nervous that this is just,
I mean, it's, it's already bad enough.
I have people in Europe listens to me,
go off on American sports
and in Australia and shit.
It's for me to actually sit
here describing drum licks.
It's pretty fucking
pathetic. But, um, anyways,
I think I'm winding down here.
I got to make sure I edit this thing
and get this thing up on time and I also
have to make sure, oh my God.
Oh fuck. What time is it?
I got to go. It's three 15. I got to be
down at the fucking place to buy four.
Fuck. All right. I gotta go. Thanks.
Listen to the podcast. Uh, God bless all.
You don't take any shit.
Go Fuck Yourself.
[inaudible] [inaudible].